there yep he's hooked on aha
Paul hooked up over there hey
still paddling away this fish he's too
Moffit you hey Paul we'll run them down
gear up they're like all right watch out
you've got to get out of my way
now we gotta get away from the rope you
come back there if a fish hits that line
the friction could snap that line this
is lobster country and we can lose them
in two seconds if we can catch this fish
we could catch up to calm some horrible
beat oh man that's why you do this to
win win win win you got you gotta get a
socket socket that's it baby like that
there you go
get on you take three yields you already
take your wheel this could be the fish
that puts us on top a lot of things
could go wrong if fishes for 48 hours
Freddie got we wrapped up in it he's got
to be around the buoy row just let up on
the drag we don't want to lose 10 grand
we need we're doing battle here close
ya see that time you get out of watch
then 15 that long I came that far from
touching the back of the suit but the
touches it's game over there we go
elevator oh there he is he's right on
top Sam Dolman up this is the fish that
could make all the difference
the typo
right here
go ahead go ahead go ahead go get my
jacket
gap I'm like we don't have Annette
Taylor all right good job Amy